In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for August 19th, on which we commemorate, the holy and
great martyr, Andrew, the commander, and the 2,593 with him.
On the 19th of the month, we celebrate the memory of the holy and great martyr, Andrew
Stratelatis and his 2,593 companions. St Andrew was a Tribune in the Imperial Army and
camped on the Eastern Frontier of the Empire in the time of Emperor Maximianos Galerius,
circa the year 305. Although he had not yet received holy baptism, he
shone as arose among thorns, both by his piety and his valor.
Antiochus, the general in chief, who was known for his cruelty towards Christians, remembered
the valorous Andrew when confronting a sudden incursion by the Persians and put him at
the head of the cohort. At the moment of engaging in battle, Andrew
exhorted his men to put their trust in Christ, who created heaven and earth, and brought
to nothing the power of the false gods. Invoking then the name of Christ with one voice, they
overthrew the enemy's ranks, and drove them across the frontier.
After this unhoved for victory, all the men resolved to be converted, but they were denounced
to Antiochus as Christians. He, instead of giving them the reward they had earned, summoned
them to his Tribunal. A stranger to all sense of gratitude, and burning with resentment,
he read them the Imperial Edicts, and reminded them of the names of eminent Christians, whom
he had already had killed.
Andrew replied that these martyrs would, in fact, have been victorious over him, and
that the torments he had inflicted on them had, for them, become trophies in the kingdom
of Christ.
Employing a cruel irony, Antiochus declared that it was fitting to give rest to a man such
as he, who had shown such courage in battle, and ordered that the saint be laid on a bed
of red-hot bronze. The order of faith and charity that burned in the heart of the valiant
martyr left him insensible to the burns, and he indeed found rest on this bed. Some of
the soldiers who had distinguished themselves with him in the battle were then seized, and
their hands were nailed to beams. They endured this torture with joy, rejoicing to share
in the passion of our Lord Jesus Christ, before even having been baptized.
As they remained unmoved in their resolution, Antiochus had them thrown into prison, and
wrote to the emperor asking him if it were appropriate to execute such a valiant officer,
with the risk of provoking a mutiny in the army and a revolt by the people who looked on him
as a hero. Maximianos replied that he should dispose of him secretly with a ruse, and
not leave any loophole for the new faith to penetrate into the army.
Antiochus therefore set Andrew and his companions free, and pretended to allow them to go wherever
they would, but the holy martyr, warned by God of this stratagem, went to Tarsus with
his men, and asked Bishop Peter to give them holy baptism.
When he learned of their departure, Antiochus wrote to Salukus, the military governor of
Celicia, so that he should arrest them as quickly as possible and put them to death if they
showed the slightest resistance. Salukus, who was himself a fanatical persecutor, hurried
to Tarsus with a fairly large detachment.
Andrew and his companions who had just been baptized crossed Mount Taurus to escape the
pursuers and went towards Metilini in Armenia. Salukus searched incessantly for them, and through
treason by a man called Martin caught them in a defile on Mount Taurus. When the soldiers were
getting ready to launch themselves on them, Saint Andrew exhorted his companions to lift their
hands in prayer rather than brandish their swords, and falling to his knees, he interceded at length
for his enemies and the salvation of the world. As soon as he had finished his prayer,
the soldiers fell on them and massacred them like innocent and unresisting lambs.
In conformity with a vow made by Saint Andrew, a spring of healing water flowed forth at the place
where he had shed his blood. Peter of Tarsus and Nonus, Bishop of Berea, who had witnessed their
martyrdom from far off, along with others of the clergy, came later to take care of their precious
relics. Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.